we'd like to give you two weeks of
paychecks as a thank you
you guys could fire us now you're not
saying that's okay cardi b is giving
hard-working essential workers a big
payday oh yes honey on the latest
episode of her facebook watch series
cardi tries the rapper with the help of
karuchi tran shows her appreciation for
grocery store workers
first cardi gathers up the employees the
best way she knows how if it's up then
it's up then it's up then it's stuck if
it's up then it's up then it's up i mean
i'm just saying all the employees please
report to i one i repeat all the
employees
report to iowa one we have an emergency
then the hustler's star who worked in a
grocery store before making it big
explains why she appreciates what they
do me and karaoke was talking about how
essential workers are so necessary when
i used to do this this would take me a
long time just be standing up and just
scanning and scanning especially
holidays
and i know there was very hectic during
the coronavirus era next cardi reveals
their special gift with a card and
karuchi channels her inner oprah
thank you for all your hard work and for
helping us feed our families
we'd like to give you two weeks of
paychecks as a thank you
thank you
thank you
all right you guys miranda
you get a paycheck jessica
you'll get a paycheck
noah you gonna pay thank you
and cardi and karuchi know firsthand
just how tough the work is at the top
right the top okay so this one i guess
is here throughout the episode the duo
tries different tasks including stocking
shelves yeah well i got so much apples
going on not a lot girl
damn slicing meat this right here i
avoid all the time i like raw meal and
finally ringing and bagging up groceries
i think these are
food yes
like cardi mentioned before she used to
work at a grocery store before her days
as a musician i cannot believe i used to
do this when i was
17 18. but that job didn't work out at
the time party have you ever been fired
from a job yeah i got fired from my
supermarket job oh that's what happened
yeah they fired me why i was really late
and i used to take off like more
discounts on my food
i was crying that firing was one of the
many things that led her to where she's
at today and cardi has no problem giving
back to where it's much deserved
[Music]